الان الى التطورات في السودان حيث ذكر
مراسل الجزيره ان الطائره العسكريه للجيش
حلقت صباح اليوم بشكل مكثف في سماء عدد من
احياء ومدن العاصمه الخرطوم لاسيما ام
درمان والخرطوم بحري واضاف مراسل الجزيره
ان الطائرات الحربيه قصفت مواقع لقوات
الدعم السريع في حي شامبات اضافه الى
مواقع اخرى في شمال المدينه تاتي ذلك فيما
تتواصل المحادثات غير المباشره في جده بين
ممثلي الجيش السوداني ودعم السريع بواسطه
امريكيه سعوديه بغيت التوصل الى وقف فوري
ومستدام لاطلاق النار هذا وقال الناطق
باسم الجيش السوداني ان مجموعات من
المليشيات المتمرده ترتدي زي الجيش
السوداني وتطالب المواطنين باخلاء منازلهم
باسم الجيش ونبه الى ان الجيش لم ولن يطلب
من المواطنين اخلاء منازلهم بل يدعوهم الى
التمسك بها وعدم اتاحه الفرصه لمن دعاهم
المخربين
فرص الجزيره بتهدد الاش
تباكات السريع في مدينه
نيال سودان
قد افادت للجزيره بان ثلاثه اشخاص قتلوا
امس في حي الامتداد في نياله غربيه
السودان نتيجه المعارك بين الجيش وقوه
الدعم السريع حسابات سودانيه على فيسبوك
مقاطع فيديو تظهر اندلاع حريق في احد
المنازل بالمدينه اثر سقوط قذيفه